Allison holker opens up in her first
interview following her husband Stephen
twitch boss's tragic death we want to
enjoy the experiences that we're having
we want to have each other there to
experience it together like I think it's
all about playing with the ones that you
love still liking them and loving them
at the same time Allison gets candid
with People magazine reflecting on her
marriage with twitch saying their love
was so real and so loud we always told
people our house was like a
choreographed dance
[Music]
sometimes fun like to have a partner in
life that I can also dance with you know
it just makes every single day so fun
twitch died by suicide in December it
has been very challenging and emotional
but you guys have brought
so much hope and inspiration to us by
sharing stories and memories and moments
and different ways that Stephen impacted
your life now Allison says no one had
any inkling that he was low he didn't
want people to know he just wanted to be
everyone's Superman and protector I have
the sweetest husband in the entire world
we're celebrating and continue to give
love continue to give laughs Allison
says she's struggled to reconcile the
Beautiful Life they built together with
the pain he felt it's been really hard
because I can't understand what was
happening in that moment he died Allison
and twitch first met in 2010 when they
appeared on So You Think You Can Dance
[Music]
they tied the knot three years later and
he adopted Wesley Allison's daughter
from a previous relationship the way we
approach life is we kind of look at life
as being our playground you know so we
like to try new things they had two
children together seven-year-old Maddox
and three-year-old daughter ziya we love
the Full House and also just like family
man like honestly they're my favorite
they're my favorite people you know what
I mean now Allison is honoring her late
husband's Legacy launching the move with
kindness Foundation to support mental
health Stephen brought so much joy to
this world and he deserves to be
remembered as the beautiful man he was
it's gonna feel a little bit different
but we know that that's our purpose and
we'll still do that to this day
and I hope that we can remember
the feeling that he gave us and remember
that we can still move from there as for
dance we connect a lot through dance
something that you love to share with
the world my best advice is to find a
dance partner that you trust and you
love and for me that's my beautiful wife
Allison
[Applause]
Allison says she hasn't danced since
twitch died but when she does it will be
a big step I know that I'll get there
he's guiding me on this path
thank you
goes
[Music]